[Music]
three two one action hey guys welcome
back to off the record or we talk about
whatever we want and today we have Mia
here she's a social media sensation and
a sweetheart and a really good person if
you click it a description box below you
could check out her YouTube channel and
all this other stuff she's got going on
but before you click anywhere and before
we start this conversation I want to
give a big shout outs to Roman thank you
for sponsoring this episode did you guys
know that if that half of men over age
40 experienced erectile dysfunction at
some point in their life did you know
that about 75% of those guys don't even
seek medical treatment for the issues so
they just have wonky witnesses oh why
not because this is why Roman has made
it easy to chat with the doctor online
with Roman you can get medical care for
IDI if appropriate from the comfort and
privacy of your own home you can handle
everything online in a convenient
discreet manner it's really simple to
get started just go to get Roman comm
slash OTR and complete an online visit
if your doctor decides that treatment
would be appropriate they can prescribe
a genuine which is way better than in
genuine medication yeah that can be
delivered and discreet packaging right
to your door with free two-day shipping
talk to the doctor
erectile dysfunction can be tough to
tackle but it's really important to get
checked out with Roman it's easy to
connect with a doctor so check the link
in the description box below for a free
online visit and free two-day shipping
and thank you to Roman for sponsoring
this video
Thank You Roman now we can all get hard
and I heard you're a real fan of fantasy
football how's how's about that oh man I
was not allowed to join any leagues this
year because because last year I came in
last place and had to get a tattoo for
my league
are you serious hard got another failed
thing I was like it's just a cute little
heart yeah like next job have to get a
real even cuter heart I was part of the
fantasy league for this restaurant also
called MRI so I had to get their logo to
turn those clear coppers that's just
okay I'm so uncomfortable
there's no like Bell plastic yeah oh how
did you take a nice place what happened
to you what happened your table I
[ __ ] found a man and I have to keep
flying overseas to see him because he
lived in Copenhagen so I could never set
my lineup I was gone basically every
weekend going to Copenhagen is not work
should do that goes invented yes and
they all dip over there cuz there's a
brand called Copenhagen yeah it's what
it is it tastes better over there I will
say cuz I used to dip in high school
what what's a dip only [ __ ] nasty men
through that yeah I know I went to
military school so you did we're in a
Massanutten military academy where's the
hassle ah hmm from like baby tell senior
year in high school
what branch no I it was Joint Forces but
it was a sister school to West Point so
dominantly army that's actually big deal
yeah it was cold or high no it was 9th
grade to 12th grade I went to military
school you did that's called Army and
Navy Academy in Carlsbad
oh you know it yeah we used to play them
like in football if we ever got far
enough yeah their basketball is really
good at the time you guys had
postgraduates - right yeah like that
that was over six months you were oh you
were there for like corrective reason
yeah educational system sucking in DC so
they my parents wanted to put me in
private school oh yeah those are usually
it's either like really good kids
yeah or then like people that got like
the parents are tired on this animal
there exactly
then how does
tie back to chewing tobacco no it ties
back into fancy football just not
sitting allowance is kind of a dick move
I will say that's a big dick move well I
just missed the [ __ ] line up like I
would miss injuries I would miss anyone
who was on IR anyone who they were
sitting so I would set my lineup before
I went to bed you do wears to bed in
Copenhagen Oh transpire in the 9:00 hour
time difference can you guys explain how
fantasy football oh I don't even know
you just explained it to me off camera
no I like to I don't know what the
Copenhagen lion is it wasn't even the
best no Copenhagen line I was just in a
different time zone so does that to do
with anything started like 10:00 a.m. on
a Sunday really did that's the most
basic [ __ ] you don't set your lineup and
your player plays then guess what you
can't change your lineup exactly I see
but but there's a lot of players who are
like game time decision so you got to be
watching and I felt network or keeping
up with the news about what's going on
in setting up my number at five minutes
before the games start more hot tip
sleeper back sleeper but positive
sleeper but it's an app that tells you
when injuries happen and when certain
players play on them you know you also
hides in bushes mm-hmm clear as someone
else that's not how it works that's not
how the draft works
oh so you you can only have it yeah so
whoever you're playing with in the
league you get to choose from those NFL
players do you see what I'm dealing with
all the time but you could also play
daily fantasy and like by players and
daily fantasy is where I start to get
confused hmm well daily fantasy is for
people who take it way too seriously
yeah I do it people who are like actual
degenerate gambler yes exactly
oh do you got you guys gamble with this
you can sometimes I don't get what you
in it she lost cuz she had a freaking
tattoo that's a bet that's different
like that's I mean you you pay most
leagues a season though it's like 200
bucks for a season or 100 bucks or
whatever people oh wow so you got to
wait till the end so it's like a pool
yeah exactly
usually a prize for first second and
third that sound fun can I join your
guys's Lee it's too late
you're the wait till next year that's
why she could enjoy well just ridiculous
questions
start from the season or else you don't
have any players you just have the
injured players that they [ __ ]
benched what do you mean what's the next
part that you could play yeah although
all the sports are going on now
basketball basketball I cannot do
fantasy basketball no way you just
please fantasy soccer
oh you don't play fantasy soccer no wait
too many games yeah like what's the
difference between basketball games and
like 3,000 more games and then like look
at baseball this is what a game every
hour yeah like it's crazy yeah baseball
baseball they just played last night I
think the plan right now finally with
the kids it's not they keep track of too
much as we're saying can you mix that
with the Washington Nationals I thought
you're doing a Super Mario look no
you're you're after reading my PTSD
right now because when I was little I
used to have that stupid [ __ ] bowl
cut that every Middle Eastern kid had
probably every Mexican dirt Aladin we've
all had bowl cuts did you have a
mustache too I still have all my says
okay can you guys do fantasy MMA oh yeah
no I wouldn't be surprising I don't know
if they have it I feel like they might
but then it's not a do you like better
hmm I mean cycling is not a team sport
you can just like fantasy cycling that's
weird that sounds ridiculous aw I'm
boring that's like that's boring as
daily fantasy as to me I'm off cycling
cycling yeah yeah I learned how to ride
a bike literally last year I've never
ridden one of my life but I've always
wanted but I went to [ __ ] Copenhagen
and they apparently don't do overs there
everyone who rides a bike boy and this
was literally the first week I met my
suit my future husband so we were just
meeting and like I wanted to impress him
and everyone in Copenhagen rides a bike
we were in like a short skirt and you're
like [ __ ] I was wondering a buckin
Zimmermann dress and then it got caught
on yo oh it's a very nice dress he gave
us too much credit how did you meet
Instagram is that right yeah okay
followed him and then he split in my
dance Oh
say what's his opener his opener was
literate so speak English I found him
through the restaurant that he used to
work out because I'm I'm really into
food and his opening line was so are you
into food you should come to Copenhagen
I'm like this [ __ ] and then that
got you to Copenhagen yeah you should
see no no six months later six months of
facetiming everyday and then I bought a
flight Calkins but like are you sorry
I'm like even buy it for you no no
because I wanted to get it and I wanted
to get my own hotel in case I got there
and wasn't feeling him then I wouldn't
be on his time I would be on my own
vacation smart fighting Copenhagen but
in Copenhagen is beautiful whoa by
winter in the winter time Oh bad
connotation when you open it no no it's
freezing it's dark it's dark like 20
hours a day it doesn't look like Bali in
the summer well she went during the
right time I went through in a long time
yeah I went during the deals time she
went during the non-duality is
Copenhagen known for the summer or for
like the winter no they're mostly good
travel ban you haven't I'd rather hear
from someone personally like it's
depressing I can have a conversation
with Geo I don't know what's good man
[ __ ] yeah go [ __ ] watch my
Instagram stories or all you'll see it
what are some good restaurants why don't
you go on Yelp fool like so you seen the
movies I don't know did I yeah now you
know why PTSD that's why I go around
tomatoes you poor victim oh no don't you
do that you don't leave our team right
[ __ ] yes [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] traumatic
syndrome back
Luzi traumatic stresses you got PTSD
yeah anyway so you went to London
recently I did what was the thing that
you kept promoting well they're not
paying me anymore I'm not gonna say your
personal thing yeah my football about
people that aren't paid by DiGiorno
anymore they still keep Playa de Jour no
I just heard of a lady that was paid by
DiGiorno du jour no auto-pay sir is it
delivery no good setup are you getting
paid by the Washington Wizards no good
just check now they would make enough
for tonight got it they can barely
afford talking oh I thought that was a
wall green sign our new team I can't
blame them mmm yeah I don't know when
did you get it the sport it's such a
sports looking low and I move to America
it was like the first thing that helped
me kind of grasp onto American culture
and or in did you hold were you it was
in 2001 from Lebanon yeah I was
graduating high school why are you gonna
hate yourself everyone thinks you're 12
no I ate myself all the time because I
look good did you learn English out
there Lebanon's know we we spoke Arabic
and loving the Lebanese and French over
there uh-huh and then when I moved to
America my parents put me in like a [ __ ]
ton of remedial English classes so that
I could catch up and be ready for school
but how do you not have an accident you
sunk friends who are here since 1993 and
they still have a [ __ ] accent no I
think it's because I was so young oh
yeah I've had friends that they have an
East LA accent and they don't even speak
what is in East LA us like you know fool
like oh he was okay yeah yeah yeah like
so later or was that like decision this
is easterly are we yeah moderate parts
might right next door so like the
culture bleeds over I have no [ __ ]
bearings I thought we were like in the
same lot as we were last time
that's the San Diego's right there with
you Lebanese yeah there's this dish and
Lebanese dish that's what you won't do
sip and paint I'll make whatever he
wants for you there's a public
inhabiting why people think is this
event is it like a dip no so there's
this clean II AC repairman uh-huh who's
Lebanese okay I need to hit on my mom
all the time and then he ended up T
wanted that Chinese pusher and then he
ended up telling my mom to come over
um and I think my mom is so friendly she
didn't know that he was trying but I
knew and then I went there kind of like
my guards up but then once I had this
eggplant being he made on my man like
diced eggplant with tomatoes yours
tomatoes what is that called uh
tabbouleh no like the salad but you know
what they should do right now subscribe
because we'll never figure out what this
dish is unless you guys subscribe so hit
that button and let us know cuz I know
we have some dope as Lebanese fans that
really really want to let us know and
they're not gonna tell us unless
everybody starts to subscribe and
apparently there's one Lebanese dish
because he was able to say with tomatoes
and she's like yep that's the one Wow
yeah lucky if I've never heard it how
many eggplant variations do you know
like 59 really yeah the backbone is like
yeah I plant olive olive oil lemon and
garlic I'm just eating I'd even like
eggplants my mom always try to force me
to eat eggplant I thought was nasty but
then I was out this dude's house I'm
like oh [ __ ] I could eat eggplant tastes
like this have to get it I am NOT gonna
support this eggplant conversation I
would like to know you know you said you
had a tray for sipping pain
what is the deal oh because you not
yes this culture you're wearing a
baseball cap right now and that is the
whitest white in the land its nails and
the valleys in the street this is true
yeah okay
but sipping paint is like a line I'm not
willing to cross what a sip in pink I
think you need to have a credit shot
that's like a blood 750 to be able to do
sip and paint and I'm just not there yet
repeat that you need a credit score
above 750 to do sip and pain that's how
white it is you don't know right white
trash people then would you smoke the
paint like I do that's different
yeah sipping and painting I feel like is
a time-honored thing that people did for
hundreds of years
well what about 40 outs a paint that
comes with the spray can though oh
you're right different kind did you know
that van Gogh you should just get [ __ ]
up and he did paint that's all he did
that's why starry night looks like that
right yeah well the medication for his
syphilis probably two shouldn't mix that
with alcohol
you got BOM wasted and he would paint
and then people are like this is sick
and he's like okay you're too mainstream
is he I was just tripping but and then
he's like I can't do it without the
alcohol I can't make good art it was
like the movie flying have you seen
flying is that the one with Denzel
Washington very same recently for the
first time degree movies before I was on
vacation and me and Robert watched it
the last night it's called flight and
it's about him landing an airplane
that's crashing while on cocaine yeah I
saw it
the cocaine helps him land the plane oh
it does yeah he was really drunk yeah
like mango and and what's really fun if
you guys want to take the challenge is
play flight while you're on a flight no
and then see what the person next brown
to do that I will get escorted off an
airplane immediately
true I mean wow dude so much it's so
annoying to travel really how do I dress
well just like a giant belt I don't
think the airplane guys are like hey
wait it's Mia Khalifa let's uh you know
I think that's what's happening yeah
what I'm getting escorting some Mia
Khalifa yeah well my poop guy
dude that was so annoying I cannot
happen what happened down off my page
just because which page my Instagram
page yeah
they removed it that was the first and
only ever posted because she's there
like not even though he's marrying a
grandma sweater and everything and the
caption was so nice I had nothing to do
with harassment bullying sexual violence
there was so your image is just sexual
now yeah and I'm trying if we're gonna
get to monetize what the [ __ ] titles
have you ever been in a gorgeous or
something and someone and you meet
somebody and they're like I've never
heard of you in my life and they're like
sweating you could always tell like no
it's happened before we're like they'll
come up to me and asked me where
something is and I'm like do I look like
a [ __ ] work here maybe target yeah I
mean it must be weird right because what
we get is you're that YouTube person and
you know that no watches you that's what
we get they're shaky they're like
they're like oh yeah 1080p shot but my
boyfriend's a big fan yeah I'm doing it
for them you take the picture and
they're [ __ ] shaking like this they
try and take it in their head off yeah
it's just one blur when they're trying
to do a selfie give me your phone
just don't be better than me man and
then they're like no really he actually
has Parkinson's on my office
they're not so how did they approach
your fans so most of the time it's in a
very aggressive way because they're men
and they feel entitled to me because
they've seen me do certain things a very
long time ago that's weird
yeah I know so I don't like leaving the
house because oh my men who approach me
just creep me out of my skin looks like
a typical man approach Steve can you do
it please you already have I actually
met a lot of these guys they used to the
famous pranks and with porn stars and
they were the guys are like that they're
very like they feel like they have a
right to [ __ ] it they grab you all this
[ __ ] when you're like oh [ __ ] it's weird
he did this really funny prank this is
how I first saw him it's like he would
he would get these guys at Venice Beach
like yeah you want to do this like
bangbus they're like oh [ __ ] yeah right
and then there'll be the girls in the
bus the girls were in the bus bags will
come in and he's like all right are you
ready for the porn stars but he's like
yeah and then the girls leave and in two
big buck guys come in yeah they've
become like the camera people yeah okay
the guys were the port and sake white
asses take one what the [ __ ] these
two guys get in the van and started like
rubbing on his legs much yeah he's cute
he's really cute would you be able to
get away with that doing it in 2019 or
do you think you'd get slept I think I
could I mean I didn't demonetized like a
[ __ ] so what could they do what
can they do left to make no that's sure
I could do it yeah but those do some
good [ __ ] oh my god I must be really
creepy yeah yeah so they feel like it's
very much like that or if they don't get
the answer they want like if I tell them
no or to [ __ ] off or sometimes they'll
approach me without even like speaking
first I'll just feel someone like
grabbing oh oh oh what do they say what
is it like when they grab my arm I
immediately turn around and say as loud
as I possibly can to embarrass them and
scare them out of doing something stupid
get the [ __ ] off of me don't touch me oh
but sometimes they yell back like
[ __ ] car [ __ ] [ __ ] touch a girl
you don't know in public that's fine
just keep pepper spray applause well in
Texas I got a gun
you shoot anybody I hope you did no Jeff
wouldn't let me hmm the only way I could
get a gun is if he kept the bullets
oh [ __ ] cuz you're just gonna go off
okay who's Jeff might manager some guy
in that room sorry Jeffrey I didn't meet
him yet oh no I thought you should have
you look nice to me one of the things I
always wanted to do maybe you can help
me perform this fantasy is you walk
around right and as a guy approaches you
I'll be waiting okay okay and then he
does the arm grab [ __ ] and I come out of
the [ __ ] I come out of nowhere and I
shoot him for you like a bush so I'm
like I'm just like hiding and then
you're you gotta be the bait okay and
then every time ya cuz I wanna like have
a reason to [ __ ] somebody up but it has
to be where I'm also a hero you know
what else we could do what get a pepper
spray can but hear me out
put ricin inside yeah fun prank they
died three days later oh oh that [ __ ]
yeah oh [ __ ] I want to I want to be like
a really beautiful you should dress up
like me I want you and then we'd have to
shave your facial hair though I know
bottle I mean Asians make the best like
passing ladies like if agent guy turns
into a lady they're like really good and
convincing so I think I could pull it
off but then I want to be in that
situation where like someone grabs me I
could [ __ ] stab them in the throat or
something I will say it's kind of
exhilarating and empowering to put a man
in his place like that like I'm I just
pulling Jeff might have to admit I
punched someone yeah so Jeff is
miserable by the way yeah I think I need
it Jeff I always say she that gets me
into trouble
listen to me I do I kidding oh so yeah
I've been grabbed at like concerts and
stuff and my immediate like
fight-or-flight reaction is to just turn
around and swing [ __ ] yeah
I like you I like you this one guy
though like this is this went pretty
viral when it happened this one guy
posted a picture of his face after I
punched him and it was like there was
nothing on the cheek that he was taking
like he looked he took the picture
posing like Rihanna for her mugshot not
mugshot but you know after the whole
Chris Brown yeah yeah yeah but there was
nothing on his face he's a little [ __ ]
for this amendment that yeah instead of
me getting hate for like actually beat
like hitting someone
he got hate for being a [ __ ] but you
know what before we leave here I want to
let y'all know I know this whole time
when you're watching the video you're
alive oh and you're gonna talk about her
[ __ ] past life cuz you [ __ ]
in cells are too damn horny and if you
want to see the whole but this year
we're gonna go deeper we're gonna go
crazier we're gonna talk about some more
[ __ ] but you got to join the patreon for
that [ __ ] we're going elbow deep
yeah there until then watch out if you
ever stop that I'm not sure I'm gonna
jump in no you can't I'm gonna [ __ ]
come over here beat the [ __ ] out of your
ass I'm your bodyguard now
[Music]